[Inaudible].
Are you okay?
Do you need help? I'm good. Why?
Oh yeah. You guys covered that up on land. Huh? I'm a mermaid. Oh,
well, former mermaid.
How do you guys use? See things. Oh my God.
Back there. Yeah. Oh, that's where my blow hole is.
So you're a mermaid, huh? Yeah. You may have heard of my friend, Ariel,
the little mermaid to me, Ana. She's not so little,
but when we were down there, she kept telling me how like amazing it is on land.
And I was like, whatever.
But then after the a hundred time of getting a fricking straw stuck up my nose,
I need to find myself a sea witch and have her turn me into a unit.
So here I am. Do you know where the princes are?
Are you gonna have those here in Florida? It's one like
two killers alligators.
So where are they come with me?
The only princess I know aren't from here
in England.
Gotta get on a plane to see them.
How we might help.
No, no, I don't work. I'm a princess.
[Inaudible].
Want some friends. No, thank you. [inaudible]
What? Well, that's a straw.
You must got in your nose.
That's what we drink. We drink the garbage.
Yeah.
I don't know what I was thinking. And coming here,
I'm going to go back to the sea,
which tell you to change me back into a mermaid now. So thank you for your time.
[Inaudible].
Does he make me into a mermaid to know,
Hey, I'm an excellent wing man. I can help you find a Prince.
No. Okay. Oh, FYI.
It's a really far way down to the sea watch and I can guarantee your lungs when
it's explode. Honestly, it's better than going out. Another Tinder day.
[Inaudible].